hello everyone a very warm good
afternoon to all of you i would like to
welcome you all to the first session of
genomics in the virtual lab
in this online program students will
learn about genomic sequence analysis
the relationship between sequence and
function as well as computational
biology methods
after completing the two week uh program
the students will gain a deeper
understanding of the computational tools
that will allow scientists to study
genomic data to understand genetic
diseases and the way our dna is a key to
more personalized and precise medicine
the program includes to our online
lectures and hands-on exercises to
provide a mix of theoretical and
practical learning opportunities
so in today's session we will introduce
you to the program the mentors give an
overview of the tools and resources for
this program which includes homicide
learn courses projects and the t bio
info analytics platform we will also
discuss about how to access these
resources and make sure that all of you
have your credentials
towards the end we will also discuss
about the expectations and should you
review for the training program and
discuss some important guidelines
now uh to introduce myself i am sonalika
ray and i'm the omnislogic community
manager and i'm responsible for the
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of our bioinformatics
community which is managed by pine
powder
so before we begin with today's
session we have some interested
participants who have joined today's uh
session and i would like to introduce
ourselves to them
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company and we are working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission here is to make
bioinformatics more accessible
and over the past several years we have
had the privilege of working with a
number of organizations developing a
training program for research oriented
students faculty and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students in
faculty around the world the omixlogic
research-based training programs are
a result of close collaboration between
pine biotech and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation curriculum review and
project design
the training follows a project based
learning approach which uses research
great tools to analyze data from top
tier review journals and the training
has been completed by students
researchers and faculties in six
different specialization tracks which
include oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on comics data
analysis
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and racial coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
cleaning resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
i would like to introduce the founders
and the team members of the company dr
alfred tauber he comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of global
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr yulin brodsky is the director of
troubled bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics and our platform is a
result of hard work by some of the
people who are mentioned here on the
right
julia panov is an expert
bioinformatician avid of scheme is the
development of t by info platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced client
for meditation with multiple
publications in top peer tribute
journals and he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project need for omisologic
training and research fellowship
and dr raghavendran lakshmi narayanan is
an accomplished computational biologist
with an experience in large scale
analysis of multinomics data and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
so now let's get into the training
program
i would like to first of all discuss
about the resources that you will get an
access to that comes along with this
program
so the omixlogic learn portal
is for practical and theoretical
learning of bioinformatics i will
shortly take you to the portal and show
you all how to navigate easily on the
portal and have an updated profile
the courses on this portal are designed
to take you through the theoretical
knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path of the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omixlogic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and an
introduction to basic coding languages
like r and python or beginning a data
analysis project
the participants will be given the
directions to access the t by info
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transcriptomics data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run these pipelines
and different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
the program comes with an access to the
omicrologic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics precision
medicine multi-omics which includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python and
also you will get the access to various
example projects in these different
fields which you could learn from and
replicate your research work
so now let's quickly uh sign up on the
omixlogiclon portal if you have not
signed up yet and if you have signed up
then we'll uh discuss about the program
page i'll be just re-sharing my screen
so here we are on the omnilogic learn
portal and this is the program page that
i'll be shortly getting back to and
we'll discuss the schedule and also how
you can access the recordings and the
associated resources that comes along
with the program but before we do that i
would really like to discuss how you can
navigate easily on this logic learn
program but before that how to have an
account and an updated profile
so i'll share the link in the uh thank
you so much oh jesse for sharing the
link in the chat box
and now if you have already signed up on
the portal please put a yes or maybe one
in the chat so that i know you have
signed up or you can take a minute and
do so so that if you face any issues our
team is here and we'll be able to help
you out with the same
i'll be taking a pause here for a minute
to allow you the time to
open up your account so that you can
also follow
the
instructions and look at the courses
that we go through in the session today
i'll be awaiting responses in the chat
box if you can put a yes or one maybe so
that i know that you have signed up and
then you can proceed ahead
all right so i'm hoping that you have
signed up now once you have an account
on the omisogyn portal the next step is
to complete your profile an updated
profile is really important because it
lets the mentors know about your
achievement and also uh it would help
you enhance your
cv so it's very important for you to
have an updated profile which includes a
profile picture
make sure
that the capitalization of your name is
in the proper format
please link in your social media
accounts and add a free file about
yourself this brief file could include
about your educational background or
your research interest and what are your
aspirations and for every course for
that you complete on the omicron portal
you will get some points for the very
same that will take you from a business
level to an expert level
you'll be able to look at your
achievement and also the mentors will be
able to monitor your progress on the
portal via this profile tab itself where
they they can see which all coursework
have you completed and
once your coursework is completed you
will be able to download a certificate
from the profile section itself and
share your achievements
now coming back to the program genomics
in the virtual lab so this is the
program page for uh the very same
program for which you are making today
i'll be putting the link in the chat box
now once you are here on the program
page
uh this page will list out the schedule
of the program
which includes when the session is
scheduled for which date and what are
the specific topics that are supposed to
be covered on that particular day so
today is july 18 and we have the first
session today the topics that we'll be
covering would be about anus
technologies in the 21st century the
role of big data in biomedicine data
resources and tools and we have
explained
what all outcomes you could achieve from
today's session and also along with each
session you are supposed to go through
some of the associated online resources
make sure that once the session is over
you go through all these lessons that we
have mentioned here as an associated
online lesson now these resources are
actually the lessons uh from the
coursework on the portal itself
these are hyperlinks so when you click
on it you'll be redirected to the lesson
please make sure that once the session
is complete you watch the recording
revisit all the topics that we have
discussed and also complete the
associated resources
we have listed out the sessions and
their schedule
here on the program page itself so the
participants will have that access to
this program page where they where they
can see all the details for the
particular session including the
recordings as well we'll go in much
further detail of each and every session
that issue
with the mentor so that was about
creating an account updating your
profile and going to the program page
for session shipping
now i would like to pass on the stage to
the mentor dr raghavendran for taking
this session ahead and getting started
with the very first session of genomics
in the virtual lab so over to you dr
raghav
thank you very much
hello everybody and welcome to the first
session of genomics in virtual lab let
me find ways to share my screen
is my screen visible
yes so we can see your screen
okay thank you very much
excuse me
so welcome to the first session of
genomics and virtual lab
online program and i'm excited to share
with you the first in the first lesson
we are going to
get ourselves introduced to
bioinformatics as a basic or what is
bioinformatics and what are the
different technologies that
that we use or what are the different
applications of bioinformatics from
genomics point of view and how big data
shaped or is continuing to shape the bio
biomedicine and research uh field in the
biological
research area so to begin with let's ask
the question what is bioinformatic
so
you can be it can be
stated as it is a convergence of all the
three aspects of uh
biology statistics and informatics so uh
who uses bioinformatics and and who is
it for and
it could be different the answer could
be statisticians could be engineers or
computer science scientists depending
upon what is the question that they ask
but
the the truth or more and more people
from biology or biologists and
clinicians are now expected to
understand and to handle their own data
and their
trends in the data to publish to succeed
in basic and translational research so
this
marks a rapid change or this marks a
phenomenal change in the biological
science itself right the science itself
is rapidly acquiring the characteristics
of data science so
so as a result what we have is a growing
interest among biologists and clinicians
for data and this data includes new
types of data like
computational methods of data analysis
for existing data and as well as
approaches to find new patterns and
existing patterns that can explain
biological phenomena or explain
different
characteristics of the biological
samples
so some of the major outcomes due to
this changes in the approaches to
biological studies include notable new
discoveries such as new treatments and
treatment options and
new diagnostic assays new design
strategies for experimentation are all
possible and the the whole world of
diagnostics and therapeutics expanded
its horizons due to the income or due to
the influx of data analytics and data
oriented biological research
so this is possible with the tremendous
growth and availability of a large
volume of high throughput genomics data
which we will allocate more time to
explore various repositories and data
types and project examples and all of
these can be used and all of these can
be leveraged to explore and understand
how generally bioinformatics analysis of
high throughput sequencing data or
genomics data
is used in biological research question
and how they are effective in helping us
understand some key aspects of biology
that has not been
that has been untouched before
a lot of breakthrough in in this
bioinformatics research are the result
of uh
high throughput sequencing technology or
next generation sequencing technology
that generates a large volume of data
billions and billions of data points on
genes
on on proteins
on on other molecules that characterizes
biological systems and phenomena
so
and these data as such are compiled into
databases and data repositories that can
be systematically studied and explored
to understand interrogate and establish
trends for many applications so one such
repository is maintained by the national
center for biotechnology information or
ncbi in short which has a collection of
all peer-reviewed or most of the
peer-reviewed biomedical articles and
biological datasets and projects on
various topics
so
one advantage of all of these
repositories interlinked with one
major umbrella database like ncbi is if
you try to open a data set from gene
expression omnibus then we will get an
associated publication link and
associated projects that is submitted or
that is that contains all the
raw dataset for that specific uh data
page
so
we can use such publicly available data
repositories to answer key questions or
to explore biological trends as as i
have already mentioned
so at the
at the fundamental level what are we
looking for in trying to explore
these data assets so we are looking for
trying to find bugs in the core so bugs
in the genomic code we all know the
genomic code codes for almost all of the
proteins and all and the function that
it is responsible for maintaining the
cells phenotypical state and functional
state so there are bugs in the code just
like bugs in any
any
data storage system so we want to
identify
these variations so these bugs so these
bugs can actually include examples
from genetic diseases or hereditary
diseases like sickle cell anemia where
one nucleotide or one base change from
t to a result in a major phenotypical or
morphological change of the red blood
cells and due to this we have a
deficient
oxygen carrier in our blood and we get
anemic response
and we will also look at some excellent
example applications of genomics like
genomic variants affecting drug
metabolism by changing the enzymatic
function we will also look at an
assorted mutations or somatic mutations
that leads to tumor genesis or tumor
development we already spoke about
sickle cell anemia but that is not the
only inherited mutations in this case
and we will also take a look at rare
genetic diseases or genetic disorder
that can arise from gene variations and
functions and finally we can also
explore development of drug resistance
in pathogens like for example
mycobacterium tuberculosis and uh and
other pathogens which are increasingly
becoming resistant to one or multiple
drugs that is used to
treat them
so to give you an overview of how this
process is done so once a
patient is actually
submitting their
samples for further analysis upon
receiving the dna sequencing vessels for
example for a sick patient the first
question that they will ask is which
genes are all affected and this is not a
very simple question simple question to
answer so therefore genomics is already
being used in diagnostics and clinical
care but many of the variants and many
of the differences that we just spoke
about which could be responsible for
the development of our onset of the
disease or the condition are
still being discovered and still being
annotated and
validated and vigorously analyzed by a
diverse team of scientists all over the
world
so for example to give you some of the
examples of these variations on their
pathological responses
we have in cancer dna variation can help
determine genetic risk associated with
oncogenes but more often oncologists or
biologists will look for mutations or
somatic mutations that
in something like
in a subset of genes which are called
oncogenes or sometimes tumor suppressor
genes or sometimes a family of dna
repair genes so since cancer is more
most often
associated or it occurs with
aging many researchers see the
accumulation of somatic mutations in key
genomic regions as a combination of
mutations that drive the tube tumor
progression and there are also other
mutations which just tag along and
for for some time they do not cause any
uh
ill effects or
they did not cause any um
terminal ethics but they are called as
passenger mutations so eventually the
with the help of genomics data analysis
it is absolutely necessary to evaluate
the risk of the severity of the tumor
propagation and
through the analysis of these different
mutations like passenger mutations and
the combination of driver mutations in
one or more involved genes right
these analysis and these evaluation will
help us select appropriate treatment to
slow down or to even sometimes
manage or maintain the incurable cancer
that is
at some stage or not metastatic stages
so one gene in particular that i want to
highlight is p53 protein gene that is
tumor protein 53 g which is responsible
for tumor suppression in healthy cells
so it is implicated in many cancers and
this gene
of
in its normal functionality prevents
tumor growth through the process called
programmed cell death or hypothesis some
mutations in this gene can lead to loss
of function and ultimately
many mutations accumulated mutations in
this gene at various different positions
will promote tumor genesis or onset of
tumor by not controlling the replication
of cells with damaged gna so identifying
these mutations or these subset of
mutations will be key in evaluating the
risk for
patients or any uh healthy person
for developing ons or for
yeah for developing tumeric genesis or
for developing picture
so
other diseases like cystic fibrosis
right can also be linked to individual
genes like this in this case it is
linked to the transmembrane conductance
regulator gene or cftr genes in which
mutations will actually uh affect the
function of the channel that is
responsible for clearing the mucus from
airways and and this is this once we
have identified these specific genes it
is also possible to target these
specific genes for
successful inhibition or successful
response or treatment responses for
cases like cystic fibrosis it is also it
is also
demonstrated that it is possible to
target these genes in cystic fibrosis
case but unfortunately it is not
always
it is not always a
responsible but for some for whom
these treatments are responsible
responsive it is very valuable
information and they are treated in such
cases
so one more
disease or some more diseases can be
inherited
diseases meaning
the aberrations or the variations that
you find in the
genomic code can be inherited from your
parents so in this case
we are going to discuss about
huntington's disease which is an
inherited condition where one specific
gene on chromosome 4 has an abnormal
count or abnormal number of codons that
cag codas so
the htt gene is the one that we are
talking about discussing and this gene
will encode a large huntington protein
and this additional repeats changes the
protein structure
and resulting in progressive movement
disorder with dementia and behavioral
abnormalities so some of the typical
signs emerge in midlife but
but heavy juvenile onset and
early onset cases can also be seen so
diagnosis is typically based on
behavioral
behavioral
examination and presence of
characteristic motor science but the
disorder will actually
result in a decline in intellectual and
psychiatric
abilities and sometimes uh death ensures
after median of approximately 18 years
so in 2015 the consortium the huntington
consortium published a study of over 1
000 individuals with early and late
onset of this disease so applying
specific targeted sequencing effect and
as well as whole genome sequencing
effort the researchers discovered that
important regulation mechanisms that
differentiated between these groups
provided insight into other mutations as
such shown here in chromosome 15 right
that were associated with slower
development of the clinical onset this
study as well as other
whole genome sequencing or genome-wide
association studies can help identify
rare mechanisms and mechanisms of
disease progression and potential
therapeutic interventions that will
leverage natural mechanisms of these
disease regulations
and uh
to change or to shift our focus from uh
uh from application to human disease
point of view uh or human data point of
view some of the important genomics data
comes from the pathogens point of view
as you would have already been
encountered a lot of information from
media about the sars pandemic the kobit
pandemic that we are currently in and
now we are actually trying we are going
to discuss about tuberculosis drug
resistance where we already know that tb
or tuberculosis uh in full form is a
contagious infection that usually
affects the lungs so it can also spread
to other parts of the body like spine
and like brain which are more severe and
this is due to a specific bacteria type
of bacteria called mycobacterium
tuberculosis the pathogen that causes it
so
this is a this was the leading cause of
death in 20th century in usa and today
most of the cases are usually cured with
heavy antibiotics program regime but
recently there are
findings that this bacteria has become
more and more resistant to one type of
antibiotic or even multiple different
antibiotic so it turns out that the
resistance is actually a result of
mutation in specific genes or set of
genes or promoters so to understand the
understanding of which genes or what
antibiotic and the mechanism of
resistance development are all large
part of developing novel drugs that will
address this surgeon multi drug
resistant tuberculosis infection
and proceeding on further from bacteria
to virus we already introduced you so
viruses are especially prone to
acquiring a large number of mutations in
a very short amount of time where this
specific virus or ebola virus is an
example of rna virus that cause severe
disease with a heavy high mortality rate
right we already know that during the
outbreak uh our epidemic of 2014 to 2016
the genomic sequencing of next
generation sequencing has been heavily
applied in near real time
time
track due to follow or to track the
spread of this epidemic and to develop
effective vaccines so as a result many
researchers are now focusing their
attention on potential mutations of this
virus and several other viruses that may
have profound effect on general vaccine
efficacy and
effect on the transmission rates of this
specific virus which is now contained
but
we want to understand a
full spectrum of the ability of this
virus to get transmitted and to
and to on their responses to actions
and this can straightaway apply to sars
kovic pandemic also which we already
know that without the effects efforts of
next generation sequencing or high
throughput sequencing we will not be
able to
quickly develop or
change or modify the vaccine that is now
available for multiple different
variants and multiple different lineages
of saskatoon
so all of these are possible using most
up-to-date technology that uses
sequences of that uses dna or rna to
sequence them into
sequence them into digital data
so
this digital data is acquired from
taking the biological sample and then
subjecting it to uh
for example steps like sharing and steps
like um
amplification and and uh sequencing
which will convert these uh biological
sample into digital sample right this
digital sample is still unstructured as
it reads only all the characters of the
genome
in in multiple different file formats so
multiple different file formats yes so
more technical
considerations need to be taken care or
need to be used to perform an in-depth
analysis
which will
prepare the data which will also
pre-process the data and map the data to
the respective whole genome sequence of
the reference
whole genome sequence reference sequence
of the
of the sample and then generate a
structured genomic data which will list
all possible variations or all observed
variations that we can find out from
sequencing our sample
so these variations can be of different
types and their effects can also be our
results can also be of different or
varied types so for example a change
in in morphological character or in
appearance might not be detrimental or
might not be
very
[Music]
dangerous or very harmful to the source
organisms but there can also be
variations that
that
creates or that results in large
morphological and phenotypical changes
or sometimes even
acquiring of novel characters or novel
functionalities
but if they are not harmful for the
samples or they are not harmful for the
host cell then they are not termed as
mutations but there are some variations
which are pathogenic in nature or which
results in harmful vessels or loss of
functionality altered state of
functionality which which will
which will completely
disable the system to function normally
so those variations are termed as
pathogenic mutations so whenever you
hear the term variations so any genetic
variation with respect to a reference
sequence of that organism is a variation
or variance and when you hear the term
mutation it's only those variants which
are
pathogenic in nature or functionally
aberrant to the
to the host
organism is termed as
mutation
so when genomic variants are discussed
both as i mentioned mutations and
variations and sometimes polymorphisms
are also used interchangeably so most of
these variants are focus of single
nucleotide change at the basic level so
some of these nucleotide chains can fall
under non-coding region of the genome
and some of them can fall under coding
regions of the genome the coding regions
code for the protein and non-coding
regions may code for proteins only code
for other functionalities like
promoter or splicing variants or
sometimes silent mutation that does not
change anything in the resulting
outcome of the organisms function
so the distinction between the variance
and mutants or variance and polymorphism
is that it is based on the frequency
with which it occurs in a population of
a sample
right um
rare mutations tend to have as we as we
already saw functional impacts that
actually completely changes from the
wild type or
which is also known as most common form
and this uh
yields
uh in a higher difficulty in obtaining
greater signal to noise ratio for the
detection of this rare mutation which is
by uh by definition it is rare to find
so in order to get
a frequency distribution of observing
this rare mutation in a in a sample so
we have to
sequence a large number of sample
populations so in contrast for example
polymorphisms that that are generally
not detrimental right or less
functionally deviant
they are variants that are
not very rare right
some rare ones are also found but they
are not very bad they are
reasonably common and they have
sometimes they might have major
functional impact also so for example
a good example of this
of these mutants or of these variations
is is from um from the mutation in fgfs
gene
that causes extremely long hair and
eyebrows and eyelashes in people which
which are not very uh yeah which are
functionally difficult for them to uh go
about in their daily life and you might
also find this is an example of of
of a mutation that causes changes in the
phenotype right and there are also uh
relationship or studies
that results in
observing one
single nucleotide polymorphism being
responsible for the
for the blue eyed variant in the
caucasian
population so
we have an example for detrimental
mutation we have an example of
not
changes no i mean we have an example of
changes in phenotypical or morphological
character of the mutation
so these applic these observing or these
uh identifying these mutations can
actually be applied
or can yield or is already yielding
significant results for uh different
different
areas of research in pharmaceutical and
bio biotechnological companies all
around the world we can for example
study uh grouping the patient by their
uh
by their
tendency or by their
yeah by their propensity to
to the onset of tumor by patient
stratification we can characterize the
disease and uh and improve the
diagnostics
accuracy we can also identify for
example
patients who are potential responders to
specific set of therapy or specific
subset of therapies so this will
straightaway fall into the personalized
medicine and and precision medicine
category and then we can also understand
the mechanisms of disease onset and
progression from the pathogens point of
view
so that we can
target specific targets that
that will help us fight this by the
spread and fight the infection of these
pathogens so from uh from a more basic
science point of view genomics research
are
trying to find
connection between the variants that we
observe and the phenotypical characters
on biological of these biological
samples can straight away lead to
biomarker discovery which can further
help us understand the
mechanisms between behind the onset of
these disease this can also help us
detect
toxicity at the in vitro stage
of
of these rare diseases they can also
help us
identify that specific
target protein from analyzing molecular
mechanisms of this drug action
which can bind to multiple different
proteins so this target identification
or target discovery is one of the key
uh steps in drug development in
discovery uh drug development a pipeline
and genomics and uh homicide analysis
contributes major
in a very high uh proportion to this
specific area and we can also understand
the repurposing of repositioning of
existing drugs which can not only be
targeted to specific targets that
they're designed for but there are also
efforts in
applying or
finding alternative applications to the
drugs that are already existing so one
popular case is a metformin drug which
is usually prescribed to
for diabetes patients found itself
repurposed to oncological treatments
so i will take some questions if you
have any and if you do not have let's go
over the
program and go over the
different sessions that we are going to
cover in the upcoming
days
if you have any questions please
put them up in the chat
so if you do not have any questions
let's move ahead so this program is
actually divided into two parts roughly
two parts right in the first part of the
program you will learn about the tools
and datasets that is
that will help you understand
protein structure and function and how
we can use different analysis methods to
understand the variance or mutations
that we observed at the genomic level
and how they translate into the protein
level whether or not the structures are
rare in the protein structures these
mutations are found and whether or not
they could affect the
functionality of the protein so that we
can
definitely cover this the second part in
a nutshell we are going to dive more
dive more into the genomics of
biomedical research so this is going to
take or this is going to consider the
omics data genomics data analysis and
and in various other applications where
they are applied in trying to understand
biology behind the infectious diseases
or
trying to understand the population of
microbial communities in our body or in
any sample generally and how they form
pinnacle to identify and to develop
antiviral drugs vaccines and antibiotics
yeah
so yeah this in bioinformatics tools and
data in the first part
we will learn about protein structure in
general and we will learn about
introduce you to
visualize protein structure we will
introduce you to ah perform multiple
sequence alignment and phylogenetic tree
analysis that can imp that we can ah
implicate at the level of protein
structure and functions
so these are all possible and several
resources pertaining to how to perform
these
can be
can be accessed
using the omix
logic data omix logics platform as
explained by nasa lika you will also
find a specific list of associated
resources that are
given to you that are listed out to you
at the in the program page and also you
will receive an email before the
beginning of or before the before every
session
okay
so this is the introduction to
bioinformatics session that we are
actually discussing and this is intended
to introduce you to various other ways
of various applications of
bioinformatics in general from a
genomics point of view so i see some
specific questions which
which asks how to
differentiate between variation and
mutation which i already told right any
variance or any variation with respect
to the
reference genome can be termed as
variation and pathological variations
can be termed as mutation and more
specific questions to regenerative
medicine target identification
you can sign up for the program so when
we are discussing in that specific
session we will have more time and more
slides to actually describe and discuss
in detail so right now if i am going to
talk to you i am going to
talk to you without pointing out
publication or without pointing out
resources and it's all going to be your
monologues so uh it's better is to uh
sign up for the program and wait for
that specific uh session where we can
discuss these in detail and how to
perform analysis to make use of these
specific target identification or
repurposing of integrals that can also
we can discuss
so in the second uh in the next session
we are going to deal with protein
structure and function as i mentioned so
we we are going to introduce you to
different genomic variants and as i
mentioned how these variants can affect
protein functions or affect protein
functions and structure in detail
so we the next session is going to be
a little bit of an hands-on session
where we learn about sequence alignment
and performing pyrogenetic tree analysis
to understand and to categorize the
variants that we have learnt so far
then we can proceed further to expand
that analysis at the genomic level to
the amino acid level and visualize in
in the structure the occurrence or the
um
or the effect of these mutations at
different levels right some
silent mutations as you will learn might
not change the amino acid composition of
the protein but some mutations may alter
the amino acid composition of the
protein heavily so we can by mapping
them onto the structure once the
structure is available we can understand
where in structure these mutations are
populated and whether or not they are
very biologically relevant we can relate
that to the knowledge that we know about
the protein and its function
and then we will learn about uh some of
the
resources and databases from where we
can extract large volumes of such data
that we can use for understanding the
understanding this analysis and patterns
in general and we will also review how
you you have been progressing so far and
then we will get a mid course assignment
where you will be given a special
specific set of
challenges to
overcome or challenges or
assignments to complete and we will also
discuss these assignments
in detail
and then in the second part of the
program we are going to talk more about
omics data analysis
and
genomics contribution in understanding
biology or bioinformatics in general
so we will start by
reviewing uh
available literatures and and we will
start by explaining to you or we will
start be discussing how to perform or
how to start or how to design a
bioinformatics project and why this is
important because there are
very
relevant
information regarding where to find data
and how to relate from publication to
data and also how to focus uh
your literature or your research
interest some of you might be very
interested in precision oncology some of
you might want to know a little bit more
about infectious diseases some of you
are really keen in understanding meta
genomics or microbial population but
these are all very broad areas so this
session and the associated resources
will help you focus that broad area into
specific research topic where you want
to
collect associated data and develop
methods that will help you understand or
help you
answer the question that you have in
mind
so we can focus in genomics in uh
genomics from the infectious diseases
point of view in understanding the
diversity and
how these variants and diversity are
helping or might help the pathogen
in its uh
transmission or in its
increased virulence and etc
and we will also understand and expand
how not one
not a single genomic sequence of a virus
but a community of microbes can be
studied using next generation sequencing
analysis and what are the different ways
they are implicated and what are the
different areas they are implicated in
biological messages this is an exciting
field of
application
of genomics research and and a lot of
interesting missiles are coming out in
microbial or microbiome or metagenomic
research engine
we will also further then focus on uh
development of vaccines and antibiotics
uh in infectious diseases categories and
where we will in detail discuss about
how a virus will actually hijack host
protein uh function protein
proteins and machinery
to perform its own function so virus are
elegant in their design that they pack
only what is absolutely necessary so in
order for the virus to successfully
replicate it has to con cake or it has
to trick the host by ah
to
supply their own protein machinery to
for its own function so we will discuss
in what are the ways that
this virus will actually progress
from infecting one cell to multiply and
we will also um
see how in generally they invade
the immune system so one of the
important ways how a virus actually uh
transmits is uh it tricks our immune
system to uh believe that they are not
uh foreign particles so this is not
always successful but when it is
successful we already know that
how
how
how dangerous it can get we already have
a pandemic situation to handle
so we will also have a hands-on session
of uh identifying data data sets and
resources from where
we can perform the analysis that we have
been focusing so far so we have been we
would have been until now be able to
perform some basic analysis on uh
genomics data be it data from its
generation sequencing or be it data that
is submitted to the repository in the
form of whole genome sequences so this
session will actually tell you what are
the different ways and what are the
different questions that you can ask
from um
uh from this available data that we can
use it to
answer these questions so for example if
you use the ncbi virus
platform you can simply ask a question
when was the first ebola whereas
genomics submitted or
sequenced right what is the earliest
ebola virus occurrence and
similarly what are the earliest sars
code 2 virus that was actually submitted
on identified what is the relationship
between sas growth to one and source
scope one source code one suspect two
sask of two and these are the ways you
can ask questions to understand
generally about uh viral
propagation or transmission so
finally you will have uh you'll have a
project presentation and and you can
actually discuss any of the project
submission
on your own which will
use the methods that we have been
discussing and the data that we have
been trying to explore and trying to
find and
and we will discuss about the um
about the tweaks that is necessary to
make this project into a successful
project you can sign up for research
project
research fellowship program if you are
interested in
continuing with the project and
and explore further how you can
make use of these data and how you can
put
the knowledge that you learned in a
practical
application
if you have any queries until now please
let me know yeah apart from the specific
questions and if we have time at the end
of today's session then we can actually
just
talk very briefly about some of the
questions that i have here from
praveenia and from
dr berkeys
so now if you do not have any question i
will pass this stage to
sunalika or sparsh i think one of you
are going to take over from me
thank you very much
hello sonalika
yes sir so we have uh some questions
that uh i would just
yes i just mentioned i just mentioned to
everybody that these questions are very
specific and they can better be answered
with a lot of supporting slides and
supporting
information in this specific session in
this respective sessions right that can
also done but now i will pass the stage
to you to uh help them out with the
registration process right
and if we have if we have time at the
end then i can tend to these questions
in a very general point of view
all right thank you so much so
now i would like to take the interested
participants through the registration
process
for those who have not registered yet
please visit the program page itself
and once you scroll down you will be
able to
register yourself by picking any of the
three options
for uh
the time duration that you would like to
enroll yourself
it could either be 45 days or 60 days or
90 days and we have listed here all the
resources that you will get an access to
along with these different times of
durations and also we have some
possibilities of scholarships with us we
have some scholarships are left with us
you can reach out to marketing advocate
on project.com thank you so much for
sharing your email address please share
your phone number as well for the indian
contacts to reach out to you directly
and as fast will help you enroll in the
program with the scholarships that you
would like to uh
take for any of the durations that you
would like to enjoy that was it about
the registration process we have
received the resources here in 60 days
you will be able to come to the research
proposal that you you can submit for
your
master's or phd application or if it's
if it's required and also frame your
research question to work on a research
project finally and the outcome of the
60 days program would be a poster
presentation and you will be able to
work on a research project and publish
it on a message current portal and also
take it forward to publish it in
a good
good repetitive journal and the outcome
for 90 days would be a research
publication that are the major
differences in these three different
access times and also
the difference lies on the type of
license that you get on the dmin for
server for 60 days the license on the d
by info server is educational and for 90
days it is a research license that you
you can pick uh that you will get and
will be able to upload data from various
uh public freely available data
repositories that you can download these
data sets and then work on them to
analyze and look at some meaningful
biological insights
so that was it how you can get yourself
registered for the program we'll be
closing the registrations in two more
days so if you're interested to enroll
and get started with your journey in
genomic data analysis uh you can enroll
yourself and proceed
so that was it that i wanted to address
uh if there are any other questions
please put them in the chat related to
registration and scholarship so that we
can address them
all right so if there are no more
questions i think we are good to enter a
session and uh if in case you have a
question that you would like it's first
to address for you for getting yourself
registered you can reach out to her
thank you everyone for joining have a
nice day